you kind of hinted at the hell that is
bankruptcy yeah walk me through that
from my nerd world the the toll it takes
on your soul on a marriage like what
does it do to the the you know you
probably tell me more than then I can
tell you my whole quality if you think
about the list of you've seen the list
we've all seen it and it's it's probably
somewhat statistically true that out of
these ten things if four of them happen
to you in twelve months you're in real
danger of hurting yourself right yeah
it's a Reming like the loss of a spouse
a loss of a child a loss of a long
career job the long hospital stay
bankruptcy divorce those kinds of you
know you get this list of horrible
things that happen to people right
well bankruptcy and divorce are on that
list right and so they're a little
different than a medical problem
obviously but you know the house fire
losing your home to fire okay is on that
list
devastating bright emotionally so what
does that do that's different than I
guess a less minor trauma it's it's an
emotional trauma isn't it yeah but it
feels like a bankruptcy would be
somebody calling you out as a failure to
yourself right it's like this it's
surrender though yeah yeah it's complete
on my loss when you when you walk out of
your marriage that's how you feel that's
I suppose I've never been through that's
exactly right but the like when you have
a divorce
if fired from a job but you think about
losing a job losing losing your marriage
is you have the loss right you grieve
the loss but there's this other more
insidious thing there which is you don't
trust yourself anymore well bankruptcies
my
yeah and that's that's what I'm asking
I've never been through it yeah that's
the same way I felt like it destroyed I
mean I was arrogant cocky it I was
powder hmm around me to powder after
that and it took me forever to get to
where I had a sense of confidence again
and part of what allowed me to do that
was finding these biblical financial
truths
something that I could have confidence
and that was beyond my own intellect
because my own intellect got me into a
mess right academia what it taught me
about money got me into a mess right and
so I couldn't that that that was a
shifting sand that's exactly build on
that yeah and so I found an anchor point
that helped me get confidence in that
and then I regained and then start
functioning regain confidence in myself
but it's a self it's a self-esteem
destroyer now people say it's not they
said yeah that was an easy divorce but I
always call BS on that a hundred percent
of the time you know that was easy that
was one of those things Morrison at the
time I tried that business idea it just
didn't work out just lost everything we
lost our house but yeah it's just I was
weak in the house and that's that's just
bravado bs that's exactly right
yeah is that it hurts that and that will
come out in other places yeah it's it's
one of those things that says you know
for the rest of your life I'm a person
that went through a divorce for the rest
of your life I'm a person that filed
bankruptcy one of the big failures so
give me one or two baby steps no pun
intended that you would like the day
after you look around and who you were
not what you had who you were
is powder what's the the little win to
to start walking your way back out of
that I think it's the benefit that I got
from it per se I think it was I figured
out I was not what I own I figure out I
was not what I do
it's the difference in being and doing
you know and so we put our put our or
having you know I we put our identity
and what we own or what we do what do
you do for a little guy sir look what
you do first question first question
right what you do well what it don't
matter right you know and what are you
what do you own it don't matter right
because there's never been a router
truck following a hearse you ain't
taking it that's exactly right so you
know all that stuff right so you go back
through that but and and so that's why I
don't want somebody file bankruptcy the
other reason that I want to file is they
oftentimes can work through it you got a
guy they're making a hundred grand for
20 grand he could clean this mess up
that's right and a lot of crap you don't
put have a lot of uncomfortable nasty
conversations with stupid people right
but twenty thousand bucks out of a
hundred thousand year he could be
debt-free in a year in twelve months he
will have experience that the Sun keeps
coming up every day yeah
and then 12 months he's he's done yeah
he shook hands and he squared up with
those folks and whatever he bought on
that stuff he'll never do it again
that's right you never do it again hmm
there's too much cost I'm fascinated by
them and I've had a few these
experiences in my life at a more minor
level but when you lose trust in your
own decision-making yeah right
you have nowhere to go but the mirror
it's a different kind of trauma it is
yeah
because in anxiety works the same way
it's it's like feeling but it's like
being betrayed by your own body you know
in your head there's nothing happening
here but your hearts racing you're
having an anxiety attack
yeah you can't breathe you're frustrated
and it's you know it's it's not real
yeah but your body's just run off down
the road on you right but it's the same
thing sitting in a horror movie I know
it's not real but still scares crap
that's exactly right yeah so I don't go
to him I get scared